what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have even more Fantastic
Four News yesterday we did a video about
how the Fantastic Four members or at
least some of them too in particularly
have been cast already and this was
revealed by Mila Kunis in an interview
on The Late Late Show she said she does
know who is playing certain members of
the Fantastic Four I am not in Fantastic
Four but I know who is
[Applause]
but yesterday we talked about the thing
and Sue storm and today we're going to
be talking about Johnny Storm it looks
like Marvel Studios has found who they
want to be Johnny Storm and they have
put out an offer to this one particular
actor to play the role of Johnny storm
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe also
today we do have some information about
the movie's villains the upcoming
Fantastic Four movie villains are
rumored to be Galactus and possibly the
Silver Surfer however today's report
tells us that there is going to be more
than one Herald of Galactus in this
movie in the Silver Surfer might not
actually be one of them now for those of
you who are worried that we might not
see the Silver Surfer we still do have
reports that a Silver Surfer special
presentation is in the work still
currently at Marvel Studios so a lot to
break down today and if you love Marvel
be sure to subscribe it's what we talk
about daily here we also have a giveaway
and a giveaway winner to announce at the
end of this video so stick around so
first things first let's talk about the
new actor that Marvel Studio has
apparently according to this rumor been
given an offer to play Johnny Storm the
Human Torch of the Fantastic Four also
just want to add that it had been said
that Marvel Studios was going to cast
Sue's storm first and read Richard's
first before they cast Johnny Storm and
Ben Grimm and according to yesterday's
report from Mila Kunis reveal it seems
like that has probably happened already
they have cast Reed and Sue and now
they're in the process of casting Johnny
Storm and Ben Grimm and this makes sense
because they need the other two actors
to play off of Reed and Sue one of them
is the best friend of Reed Richards the
thing obviously and the other Johnny
Storm is the brother of Sue storm the
younger brother so it would make sense
that they would cast Reed and Sue first
who were going to be married in this
movie according to reports and then get
other great actors to play off of these
two characters but according to Industry
Insider Daniel rpk he revealed on his
patreon Marvel Studios has offered the
role of Johnny Storm the Human Torch to
Paul meskal Paul is an Irish actor and
he hasn't been in that many big name
movies but he has been in some really
good movies nonetheless he was also in
the TV series normal people but what's
interesting about Paul is that he does
have the look to play a Johnny Storm and
he is considerably young he's 27 years
old and I say that he's young because if
the rumors and reports are true that
Adam Driver is indeed our Mr Fantastic
well Adam Driver is 39 years old giving
them a 12-year gap which is important
because if they're going to stick to the
age Gap in the comics between Sue's
storm and Mr Fantastic then this kind of
works out because Johnny Storm is
younger than Sue so if they're going to
make Mr Fantastic in the MCU around 35
to 40 years old they'll probably make
sue storm around 30 years old as well
which would mean Johnny Storm should be
around 25 to 30. they don't have to
stick to an exact age gap between the
two of them and Marvel has even retcon
this in the comics as well they had that
10-year age gap between Sue and read
Richards but then they realized that in
the story Sue met Reed when she was 11
years old and he was 21 years old so
that made it kind of weird in the comics
that they got married eventually and she
was only 11 when they first met so they
ended up changing that and of course in
the MCU they could change anything that
they want they could make them the same
age it doesn't matter it's a completely
new universe separate from the comics
obviously but I think he could do a good
job and if this report from Daniel rpk
is correct then Marvel Studios thinks he
could do a good job as well so we might
have our Johnny storm right here with
Paul meskel so let me know what you
think about this casting choice in the
comments down below let us know all your
thoughts now moving on to the villains
of the Fantastic Four like I said it
looks like the Silver Surfer isn't going
to be the herald in the Fantastic Four
movie but like I said a project is still
coming with the Silver Surfer we'll get
into that in just a bit but The Insider
account my time to shine hello tweeted
this morning stating that terrax is
going to be the herald of Galactus in
the Fantastic Four movie now don't worry
I'm going to explain who Terex is for
those who may not know and if you're
looking to get more comic knowledge you
should head over to my buddies at
comicbookdirect.com they have created a
website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up hit 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below so Terex has a very
interesting story especially when it
comes to the Fantastic Four this is at a
time in the comics where Galactus was
getting mad that his Heralds basically
had moral compasses like the Silver
Surfer norn rad so he decided that The
Herald that he needed to guide him to
fertile planets to where he could get
energy from needed to have basically no
moral values but here's where it kind of
gets interesting the Fantastic Four end
up going to Galactus to ask him to help
them defeat the Sphinx Galactus said
okay but only with one condition Terex
whose original name before he became the
herald was tyros was ruling a city
called lonlock and he basically Enslaved
the city so Galactus basically said I'll
help you if you help me get tairos to
making my Herald the Fantastic Four
agreed but reluctantly but it happened
Galactus helped them defeat him and then
they helped Galactus get tyros who
became terrex as his Herald and his plan
worked terrax had basically no moral
compass he didn't care about the people
on the planets that he went to and he
even annihilated parts of some
populations himself which made Galactus
happy and he has crazy cool Powers he
actually has control over Stone and and
when Galactus made him terrax when he
made him his Herald he got even more
power from him to the point to where he
could control all of the stone and the
surfaces of actual planets so he has
crazy strong Powers Plus not to mention
Galactus gave him the weapon called The
Cosmic ax which was capable of
generating waves of cosmic Force so it
would seem like his lack of moral value
would work out for Galactus however his
lack of moral values also meant his lack
of loyalty to Galactus he served him at
first out of fear fearing galactus's
powers and what he would do to him if he
defied him but eventually he conquered a
sphere and would defy galactus's wishes
so he is a huge force to be reckoned
with and honestly if they put this in
the movie it's gonna be really cool to
see however according to Alex P over at
the cosmic circus Alex reported that
there's going to be more than one Herald
of Galactus when my time to shine hello
tweeted Herald of Galactus for the
Fantastic Four movie Alex replied with
one of them anyways implying that there
is going to be more than one however and
everybody is really talking about this
this morning according to The Insider
can we get some toast they State a
Silver Surfer project is going to stem
out of the Fantastic Four movie but the
Silver Surfer will not be in the movie
so it seems like we're going to be
getting a couple of Heralds in the film
but the Silver Surfer will come after
now I'm assuming that he is already
going to be the herald of Galactus it's
not just going to be known red you don't
call noran Rad the Silver Surfer unless
he's already became the herald so I'm
assuming that the Silver Surfer has
defied Galactus or perhaps he still is
the herald of Galactus and maybe in the
MCU Galactus does have multiple Heralds
either way it is said that a project is
coming specifically and solely about the
Silver Surfer which I am really really
excited for perhaps they're saving him
for the next Fantastic Four film because
we know there are going to be many
Fantastic Four films once they debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so a lot
happening with the Fantastic Four let us
know all of your thoughts about all of
this news in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and leave a comment to enter
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
and a big congratulations to last
month's Winner YouTube user Joker Hamza
Studios I have sent you an email to the
one that is on your YouTube page get
back to me and we'll get you your prize
for those who didn't win we do this
giveaway every month so you'll have many
more chances you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof